hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video auf meinem kanal meine lieben
freunde ihr seht es bereits in titel
eingeblendetes teile heute youtuber um
da steht im titel weil ich das heute
mache ich habe mir für das heutige video
eine app gekauft und zwar heißt die app
you can make up das ist sie nicht
gesponsert oder sonst irgendwie was
haben und wir haben verschiedene
möglichkeiten wie beispielsweise make-up
kamera photo maker punkte von filter
nailart wir kümmern uns heute allerdings
um das schminken von youtube ich würde
sagen ich fange direkt an mit mir selber
clique dementsprechend auf make-up
kamera und wir sehen schon ab oder ist
der ist auf you can make up auf den
standort warum brauchst du meinen
standort wenn du mit schminken willst
was nicht wird auf jeden fall sagen
wollte war das hier schon ein extrem
krasser weichzeichner drauf liegt oder
man schaut euch das mal an dem handy
habe ich gerade fast gar keine poren der
wir uns jetzt auf jeden fall
verschiedene möglichkeiten wie bei
schützen
[Musik]
ja das kann ich hier machen
es ist das ach so da kann ich intensität
glaube ich ein ständer okay bei null
hier sieht man gar nix 500 stellen weg
ich bin begeistert wie krass das
funktioniert ich klicke auf
[Musik]
hallo
ich finde dass sie gerade alles auch zum
ersten mal raus wichtig jetzt mal
bildschön hatte so war quasi bildschirm
das ist sexy
wir haben auf jeden fall extrem viele
werden noch honigsüß wir haben verträumt
wir haben noch rauchig wir haben noch
schwan
hey du springst du dich heute schwan
allerdings haben wir nicht nur look
sondern wir können doch speziell aus
make up gehen und können dann sagen hey
wir hätten gerne das make-up ein
bisschen mehr so oder so und kann das ja
noch ein bisschen hochziehen einem sagen
wir mal so
mache ich mir noch dunkler ich finds
krank wie das funktioniert also unser
make up haben wir ausgewählt deswegen
lege ich jetzt mal aufruf heißt es
glaube ich das mache ich mal rot und was
man ein bisschen den lippen nehmen eine
ganz verrückte farbe und zwar grün
machen wir dann hier auch mal ganz hoch
im glossar mal ein bisschen blöd
[Musik]
ich habe ein bisschen angst vor mir
selbst gerade die haare können wir auch
noch verändern und können beispielsweise
das ganze einfach mal so machen
hey was geht denn hier ab
operiert was ist denn ich sehe aus wie
ein clown aber gut meine lieben freunde
ich würde sagen das passt dann auch so
vom make up herrlich wird neuer kurzen
foto machen da ja das bin ich mit
make-up allerdings bisher bereits im
titel eingeblendet die schminke heute
nicht nur mich beziehungsweise teile
nicht nur mich um sondern auch andere
youtuber von würd ich sagen machen wir
direkt weiter mit montana black da bin
ich sehr gespannt wie
das ist ich bin echt begeistert
wie ist diese apps also sieht ja
wirklich es sieht wie es sieht wirklich
wie das sprachenlernen
das sieht wirklich mega krass aus haben
wir hier gerade schüchtern dann haben
wir noch bild schön sexy also klar hier
ist kommt das jetzt natürlich so krass
zur geltung wie bei mir gerade weil er
halt ne camp ins gesicht gezogen hatte
es ein bisschen kleiner das gesicht auf
dem foto aber ich würde sagen dann eben
einfach mal koralle ziehen dazu hoch und
daher ist das grund die grundausstattung
des make-ups funktionen
das tolle daran dass wir das ganze jetzt
allerdings mit einem foto hier machen
und nicht mit mir wie ich irgendwie mich
rum bewege ist dass wir verschiedene
möglichkeiten haben die beispielsweise
diesmal funktion und können jetzt sagen
das ist echt beschissen aber das mag ich
eigentlich ganz gerne mal wieder dass er
ja schon scheiße aber dann ist das
wieder voll geil was wir haben und hanna
black jetzt auf jeden fall ein bisschen
zum lachen gebracht jetzt können wir das
gesicht gehen und können die
gesichtsform ein bisschen verändern und
sehr beliebt da war ordentlich breit aus
die nase können wir ja auch noch ein
bisschen verändern
die mache ich mal so ein bisschen so
hochgekocht ist wie so ein schweinchen
dann können wir jetzt noch ganz viele
benutzen das ist
was der concealer wird auf erkannte ich
habe immer mehr das gefühl dass die
edgar nicht so richtig einfach nur so
eine make up ist sondern dass sie auch
wirklich was kann die bereits gesagt
will ich überhaupt nicht groß werbung
machen für die app ich werde hier für
mich bezahlt oder sonst irgendwas aber
wenn ich produkte fire oder seal
appsfire da keine ahnung was dann sage
ich euch endlich feiert gerade guck mal
was die app alles kann das kann ich denn
noch machen ich mal face paint das war
krass bei montana blick
und die auch eine rolex krone wie ihre
tochter neben der buxtehuder
postleitzahl kommt jetzt auch noch dass
sie als nächstes dann benutzen wir jetzt
allerdings nochmal ruhe geben können
damit jetzt einfach so mitnehmen
die fangen noch ein wenig versüßen sage
ich mal warum aber warum geleuchtet
seine kette eigentlich lila das ist auf
jeden fall montana black den wir soeben
geschminkt haben speicher das foto auch
noch mal kurz ab und jetzt machen wir
weiter mit meiner absoluten lieblings
youtube drin
ein riesenapplaus meine damen und herren
für babys beauty palace die haben wir
vorne auch schon wieder klingen jetzt
einfach mal drauf was wir hier dass sie
krank aus also nicht mich krank im sinne
von wow das sieht echt mega schubert und
im sinne von dass die app wirklich mega
mega gut funktioniert ich mensch schaut
euch das mal an also dass es überhaupt
nicht böse gemeint wie wir gegenüber sie
ist halt einfach nur wirklich überhaupt
nicht mein typ vom äußeren aber wie das
alles hier sich darauf anwendet wichtig
hier draußen das ist nicht so von wegen
wir realisieren dass seine lippe ist wir
machen das irgendwie soundso sondern
schaut euch das an das könnte wie sie
könnte sich wirklich so geschminkt haben
finde ich und jetzt hier cool oder so
dass das könnte so das foto sein finde
ich das foto ist so und mit dem filter
auf 100 prozent ist es so
wie krank ist es bitte was man
mittlerweile alles mit der technik
machen kann ich entscheide mich
allerdings dennoch für diesen fortis
look weil da die lippe noch mal ein
bisschen krasser zur geltung kommt dann
gehen wir jetzt allerdings auch wenn
diesmal funktionen können sagen sie soll
ich mache auch mal weiße zähne manchmal
noch weißer tee krass okay machen wir
direkt weise mit dem gesicht hier vorne
und zwar die letten können wir das ganze
hat sie zu sehr wie michael jackson
gegen die aus gerade die gesichtsform
hatte ich bei montana black ja gerade so
das passt allerdings nicht ganz so zu
baby deswegen würde ich die gesichtsform
das komplette gegenteil machen so und
die kind form können wir wieder so und
also ich finde es krass dass diese app
das alles erkennen
irgendwie sieht ein bisschen aus den
klauen und ich habe angst vor ihr nase
verändern wir auch noch mal ein bisschen
die nasenrücken auch noch mal ein
bisschen und die länge ziehen wir auch
noch mal ein bisschen die nase zimmer
diesmal nach unten
dann gehen wir jetzt mal rüber ins make
up jetzt ist es endgültig ein clown
gewordenen rouge auf den wangen darf
natürlich auch nicht fehlen
mal rüber in die konturen und wir
betonen noch mal was ist ein betonen
digger einbetonieren oder ob wir haben
hier ist so viele möglichkeiten
ich habe gar keine ahnung was ich
irgendwie auch alles aussehen soll damit
noch markierungen können wir noch machen
nämlich wird die einfach verlassen
ich kann auch afrika noch an den augen
wir können wir können auch nicht ihre
augenfarbe der kann auch noch die
ich habe ein bisschen angst vor der
technologie immer wenn ich mir solche
face changing apps runterladen oder so
denke ich mir
die könnte man ja auch für irgendwas
negatives missbrauchen so wisst ihr was
ich meine
man kann damit ihr enorm viel
schwachsinn machen aber wenn man es
irgendwie gefährlich nutzen will dann
ist es auch möglich weil guck mal wie
ich sie hier gerade verändern kann die
person
koaliert die das sieht genau so aus als
wären dass sie ihre echten augen aber
wenn ich dann erstmal wegnehme sind sie
nicht ihre echten augenbrauen wimpern
sind vor allem luca ich bin dumm tut mir
leid die augenbrauen verändern war
allerdings auch noch mal ein bisschen
wir passen die form ein wenig an machen
die nämlich so und die farbe machen was
hohe und ich würde sagen so speichern
war die b b
wir machen noch eine letzte youtube aber
dass ich am mega krass dieselbe person
die dem heutigen video umstellen werden
ist katja glaser wird schiessen neben
babys youtube alles auf jeden fall auch
meine lieblings youtube die sache ist
allerdings dass sie hier schon sehr sehr
krass selbst geschminkt ist schon ein
wenig ja fast drauf clicquot cases es
ist trotzdem krass schaut euch das an
das könnte beides die realität sein also
ich bin vollends begeistert von dieser
app ich meinen schaut euch das an klar
sie sind jetzt hier irgendwie aus wie so
ein püppchen weil sie halt schon vorher
kranke schwingt war enorm viel
weichzeichner noch darauf warte ich
jetzt bekomme ich denn die ganze zeit
versehen drauf man schaut euch allein
gegen die den hintergrund an die
mannschaft dass da schon alles ist und
hier ihr gesicht sodass eine menge menge
mutter gearbeitet mit foto effekten
allerdings schaut euch das an ich bin
ich bin ich bin verliebt in diese app
also ich würde es nie benutzen weil ich
gerade auch auf instagram wenn ihr meine
bilder kennt bisher dass ich ein mensch
bin da eigentlich keinen kick gibt auch
irgendwie haut entfernungen oder und
entfernung andere leute entfernen also
sitzen auf jeden fall herzlich egal ob
man pickel sieht oder nicht ob ich
putzen muss vor der kamera oder nicht
ich glaube ich habe mich doch
mittlerweile schon relativ gut
allerdings schaut euch das an dieser app
das ist ja wahnsinn also dass diese app
kann es krank das ist wirklich keine
bezahlte werbung sagt zum tausendsten
mal und das heutige videos auch extrem
kommen wir können
schaut euch das an
ab
[Musik]
ich habe angst vor
technologie ich habe wirklich schiss
davor was die zukunft bringt darüber zu
den augen
die augen hat sie glaube ich auch schon
chris bearbeitet bei dem foto im
manchmal allerdings auch noch mal
komplett blau da mache ich bei den haare
da können wir keine harte klappen jetzt
nicht so gut das heutige video sei
allgemein so komplett anders wie die die
ich in den letzten tagen beispielsweise
hochgeladen habe wo ich eher so mir
sachen rausgesucht habe die euch gezeigt
habe so ebay fans beispielsweise oder
sowas und auch morgen kommt der wieder
tik tok tuesday und heute probiere ich
einfach so ein bisschen rum ich bin
absolut begeistert also die app heißt
auf jeden fall you can make up ich hab's
euch unten in der beschreibung mal
verlinkt an der stelle ich das heute
wieder beende meine lieben freunde wenn
euch das heutige wieder gefallen hat das
gern einen daumen hoch unter dem video
weiter schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare
ob ich eventuell ein teil 2 von machen
soll
[Musik]